tesla avait construit une arme de
destruction massive un rayon capable de
détruire une flotte de 10000 avions à
plus de 400 km de distance il appelle ça
le téléphone ça l'arme de dissuasion
parfaite qui empêcherait toutes les
guerres une bombe atomique avant l'heure
on est dans les années 30 la guerre
approche alors le monde entier s'y
intéresse les journaux appellent ça le
rayon de la mort problème on ne comprend
pas comment ça fonctionne une sorte
d'accélérateur à particules capable
d'envoyer des ions métalliques à 400000
km/h grâce à la répulsion
électrostatique Tesla affirme que ça se
base sur des nouveaux principes de la
physique dont personne n'avait jamais
rêvé mais il n'en fera aucune
démonstration à sa mort en 1943 le FBI
engage un expert pour décrypter ses
plans savoir si l'arme est dangereuse au
bout de deux jours il rend son verdict
c'est du vent le téléphone n'a jamais
existé les plans n'ont aucun sens Tesla
a menti à l'époque il était âgé et
manquait d’argent et cette invention
renforcée sa célébrité mais ça n'empêche
pas certains de crier au complot et
d'affirmer que